when it comes to data analytics and
sports baseball has led the way the
heart of the game is the one-on-one
confrontation between a batter and a
pitcher and there's a clear start and
end to every play now think of
basketball players switch from offense
to defense in a moment and move freely
all over the court to understand
basketball you need to understand space
it's a mapping problem and that's why
cartographer Kirk goldsbury is one of
the most exciting researchers in the
game basketball is clearly a spatial
sport what I mean by that is the courts
space is a character in the play and for
the most part basketball analytics until
very recently had just ignored that fact
every year in the NBA NBA players take
about 200,000 field goal attempts and
each of those field goal attempts is
accompanied by an XY cordinate that is
the key key ingredient to the court
Vision product goldsberry's method
starts with dividing the court into
1,284 1T areas by tracking the shots
taken and made by every player in the
league League he can establish a
baseline expectation for the value of a
shot in a certain spot and then compare
individual players to those baselines so
sport view is this crazy crazy system
it's essentially a tracking system for
every moment of a basketball game it
works by hanging six cameras in the
rafters of NBA arenas and tracking the
player locations 24 times per second and
the location of the basketball 24 times
per second it's giving these guys game
sort of an MRI and exposing where their
real strengths and weaknesses are the
data is so valuable that the NBA paid
for the installation of the cameras in
every arena in the league before the
2013 2014 season but now that all that
data is available the trick is to know
what to do with it when I first got the
data the first thing I did was sort of
look for people that could help me and
so I targeted a few people in the stats
Department in Harvard that I knew were
working on relatively similar projects
the most exciting part of this research
for me has been being able to see a data
set of this quality for something that
is this huge so there are about a th000
games in the season and 10 players on
the court and each player has uh two XY
coordinates that are collected at 25
frames per second so the number of like
SpaceTime data points ends up in the in
the billions the data comes in basically
a big text file and then we read the
data from that database using one of
these programming languages say r or
python and then I can work with that
data interactively and say pull up a
possession and look at the positions of
all the players at a particular moment
in a particular game a lot of the time
when people come across a giant data set
like this they think that the insights
are just going to sort of jump out at
them automatically in fact most of the
time you have to choose what sort of
angle you're going to take to figure out
how you're going to turn this data into
some kind of insight expected possession
value takes a particular moment in a
basketball game and assigns it a point
value based on how many points we expect
the offense to score before they give
the ball to the other team if you take a
look at LeBron James he is one of the
most effective scorers overall in the
NBA but if you just look at his overall
numbers it's deceptive two years ago he
led the league in both points and field
goal percentage in the paint which is
incredible outside the paint he's more
average he's not bad but he's just
average whereas somebody like Kevin
Durant is really good everywhere but he
lacks that really dominant aspect that
LeBron has near the basket one of the
things I think that's coolest about this
player tracking data set is that it
really is challenging us as scientists
to ask bigger questions about movement
whether it's traffic or whether's the
movement of people in cities a lot of
the concepts we're working on will
inform our future work in non-basketball
domain goldsberry's analysis opens up a
new way of evaluating everything that a
player does on the court just call it
what Goldsberry and his team do data
PA